question I wanna ask you guys is what do
you think about the recent movie reboot
that's been going on cuz I've seen some
images Lord Zedd really evil I've only
seen one picture the Red Ranger
black Ranger's meant to be a street
fighter just let me get your ideas ports
on that if you have any thanks for
telling us how it is yeah I think it's
amazing I think I think it's great for
the fandom you guys have been asking for
it forever and I think they're very
smart to do a reboot of Mighty Morphin
because that was probably the most
popular out of all the series and who
knows you guys got to write them lots of
letters and tell them that we all need
to make cameos in that movie they need
the Mighty Morphin casters show up I'm
excited about the movie I think the fact
that the reboot movie is gonna inspire
an entire different generation of people
to enjoy the Power Rangers and what we
started in I think it's pretty exciting
cuz I'm like wow I mean guys it's 21
years later and here we are we're still
still talking about it was still doing
it and a new movie especially a movie in
the vein of like transformers would be
really exciting yeah carried on from the
last question if say you asked right
this second to be in the reboot even as
a cameo would like what would you say
it's more for done saber-tooth Tiger
Triceratops
that's why I like yeah I think we would
all be very totally open to it and would
love to do it oh yeah
you